hey everybody welcome to led live have
you ever wondered is there any serious
problem with movies with witchcraft in
them
find out on this episode of led live
light exposing darkness welcome back
everybody we are excited because we have
a new person on our team
alex castillejos welcome to the team
he's finally made it out here from
california no oregon sorry oregon on
fire
yes yes so all the fires that happened
he finally decided to come over here to
tornadoville
so right we're excited to have you and
welcome aboard
he's gonna do a lot of our content in
spanish so um you know if you guys
uh have any need for spanish content
he's gonna be pumping some of that stuff
out and we're very excited about that
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
yeah it's awesome so cool alex tell us a
little bit about today's topic
well uh you know the title is modern uh
and this thing is coming up with
you know uh halloween and the day of the
dead and
mexico you know in spanish you know the
dia de los muertos
and growing up in mexico it's a culture
thing
it's growing up and you know even though
that i grew up you know as a christian
you know it's around you you know it's
this is part of
you i mean you can you know you can just
put it that way yeah you go to walmart
and there's skeletons hanging from the
ceiling and
yeah yeah yeah and you know and later on
you know i'm gonna share with you guys
you know pictures
and and the tradition you know of mexico
and
i'm sure latin america is a little
different but mexico is very
very heavy uh but i just want to share
with you guys
uh you know growing up you know watching
those those
some movies uh uh witches you know we
were talking about
holy uh halloween uh uh october 31st
uh i remember this movie and
i was i was kind of scared you know i
was kind of like you know so
it's i mean i'm i'm sure you guys
watched this movie before and it was
kind of like
comedy you know stuff like that but i
mean it shows you know the devil there
and
very magic you know practical magic
thing and
let me tell you that was like maybe
early 90s or something like that or
maybe
late 80s yeah my parents wouldn't let me
watch that one so i actually missed out
on them but
just looking at it they look goofy they
look like they purposely made to look
ugly ugly you don't want to be these
people it doesn't look like so your
parents wouldn't let you watch hocus
pocus
yeah my parents were the craft they were
kind of against witchcraft
well anything that looked demonic or
something like that nightmare before
christmas and things like that but it
didn't take long before i started
hanging out
friend's house and there it is i'm gonna
watch it there right right right and it
seems like every culture
or every generation has had these kind
of things coming back around right i
mean
for you guys these these are probably a
little bit older what would be for your
generation yeah
type of stuff that was a big no twilight
household twilight yeah that was also a
no can i ask a question though have you
seen him
no i actually haven't wow that's awesome
like the same with mikey going to
friend's house and you i would see clips
but i haven't seen anything from
start to finish i haven't read any of
the books i remember when i used to go
to movies a lot and you know how you'd
like be waiting for your movie to come
and you'd sort of duck in another movie
i remember ducking into harry potter one
time and just being like what is this
it's like all this sorcery and
witchcraft and like for whatever reason
even though um
i kind of walked away from the church um
i just was never
drawn to that kind of stuff either like
just i sort of always had this in the
back of my mind that it's wrong
and just you know knew that i shouldn't
be seduced by it
like i did and a lot of other people
yeah yeah but like i said you know
growing up in mexico and you hear
all this the day of debt is so popular
and
witches and and you know legends and all
the stuff you know
of mexico you kind of like questioning
yourself you're kind of like
oh it's kind of interesting you know and
when you see you know
uh movies from hollywood you know and
flying things and all stuff like hey i
want to go check it out right
so early 90s you know in high school and
i mean the movie i mean i'm sure you
guys if you guys
this movie i know i mean you got maybe
like 30 uh
up you know you know about this movie
the craft yeah and let me tell you when
these movies show up
when i was in high school i mean it's
like
the movie i mean like all the teenagers
you want to dress like that you want to
act like that even how they look like
that and and
it's not just about the appearance but
it's like what they doing
you know what it mess around with the
little fire you know
yeah and ran and all started powers this
movie made it look so realistic
every time i tell every time i share my
testimony i have to talk about this
movie because
this is what looks like it was more
realistic than harry potter and all that
kind of stuff this was like whoa
and so i started digging around the
internet and reading forums of people
who were
practicing wicca and it just made it
look really attractive for one you got
four hot chicks and they're yeah you
know playing with witchcraft and all
that
but yeah it's just really enticing and
uh
makes it look more realistic not
fairytale you know yeah yeah yeah
because it was like four girls in high
school
you know what i said it was not like
like a hairy party you know like in some
castles
more relatable yeah that's right that's
right but let me tell you
i mean like i said you know this movie
was uh
so interesting about wicca like what
you're saying and yeah
i mean we didn't know and that time you
know what a week it was well
me and mexico you know like but now i
mean it's a religion you know
and practical religion uh so realistic
uh
yeah it's kind of hard and a little a
little confusing as well
growing up when your religious beliefs
and your
home lifestyle is very different from as
soon as you walk out the door all of
society
is totally like against what you believe
so
in school i mean i went to christian
school we didn't celebrate halloween but
they gave out candy
when we left for the day so it's like
okay we don't celebrate halloween but
they're giving us candy so it's like our
bits and pieces okay or
you know it's just trying to i guess
live in this world but also try to stay
unspotted
it's really interesting what they do to
make things attractive because i'm
saying you know
scotty like never was into the harry
potter stuff never really into the
witchcraft stuff but
that movie the craft that's one i did
see oh yeah
and i want to say it's probably because
there was four girls in it and i was a
teenager
and so that's probably the hook you know
that's what made it appealing
um but even you know with people being
fascinated with the dead you know it's
like
it was in the james bond movie the last
one spectre you know they had this whole
scene on dia de los muertos it was all
done in one take you know
that all the people in the colorful
costumes but you think about coco
right that's right very colorful right
made to be
really visually appealing so they're
always using some kind of visual appeal
as a hook those are kids cartoons yeah
otherwise
you know it's like wait a minute like
witchcraft stay away yeah
that's generally what the thought is you
know it's like just stay away but that
there was a hook right yeah now i don't
remember like maybe you guys can refresh
my memory because i think i did see this
movie as well in high school but i don't
remember what the
what what what it was about i mean three
witches
they were in high school and they just
were practicing witchcraft and when the
new girl came to their school
they're like there's something about her
i think she's like the missing link or
whatever but she was
new didn't know anybody so they
gravitated towards around like hey
you know befriended her and you need the
fourth so you can
gain the fifth yeah right exactly i mean
i think that's the fourth premise
and then the spirit yeah and then the
fifth is the spirit yeah
the fifth element wow wow yeah i didn't
realize how like
satanic you know that idea is and
they sort of glamorize it for sure yeah
and nowadays
you know uh you know we talk about like
modern you know witchcraft you know i
mean that was back then
but i'm sure a lot of people if
you know yeah it was kind of missing all
the stuff i mean they're watching again
it's that like
you know they like their eyes it was
kind of edgy for its time
where we're yeah but now
uh you know we have netflix right and
this is uh
sabrina you know adventures of sabrina
and and seriously i don't know if you
guys watch or something i just watch a
little
the beginning you know just to have a
little that the show it's like a sitcom
and she has like a cat
or something it used to be used to be
that was in the 90s that it was
something like
that was the team version yeah that was
just like uh
because i think it was even called
sabrina the teenage witch wasn't it yeah
that one too
but that's what i'm noticing now all
these shows that
we grew up on or parents even grew up on
they're re-releasing but it's so much
darker
sabrina the teenage witch of course is
about witchcraft you shouldn't watch it
anyway but they made it comical
light-hearted now is a straight-up
pentagram and it's written in blood
and there's even a show also about um
the archie comics you know our parents
grew up on the archies or whatever oh
yeah there's a show about it now it's
named off it's named after what their
high school is called or something
it's so dark they play ouija boards and
everything she has the botha met horns
on there
yeah yeah it's kind of hard to see
because the picture's so dark
yeah yeah look at what is an interesting
picture
yeah and she's laying down in a
pentagram
with like a eight ball which is you know
typical of
of you know asking for spirits questions
and things and then of
of course a book that is
let me tell you when you see that i mean
you see
there's a seduction so that actually you
know and you know
notice she's wearing red as well which
is kind of interesting red lipstick yeah
you can tell it's it's supposed to be
seducing just like the craft was
so this girl is a teenager in high
school
he has a book so i mean we talk about
psychology thing you know i mean like
she's gonna teach you something or what
she's starting about
you know i mean it's not just like oh
yeah she's going to high school you know
but if you just in the first episode
they
show you how she become a witch
step by step why do you need to be
filming
that so people are gonna do it you know
i mean the practitioner you know
practice that
uh yeah yeah there was another movie it
came out in the 70s i think but they
redid it
uh what was the name of suspiria
remember that one
oh that's real yeah so the new one
it was who's those people uh truth to
truth i can't remember the girl and the
guy that do the truth stream
went to see it just as so they could
like break it down and they said they
had to walk out of it it was so gruesome
wow they they had a scene where there's
like naked girls and they're
slitting each other's stomachs open and
it was really like
a wicked some kind of page or
pagan ritual you know right there on
screen
so they're coming they're getting more
and more bold about showing ritualistic
things like eyes wide shut and stuff you
know they just put it right there on the
screen right
so that you're actually participating in
it right and i hear a lot of you know
things like here you know
in little live studios you know how
hollywood is doctrinating the
masses right yeah and seriously it's
like they're teaching you know well you
gotta wonder when there's so much
witchcraft terminology with the media
system you know what i mean like media
is the plural form
of medium and you've got like you know
you change yeah hollywood the witch is
one that uh you know puts people to
sleep then you've got like they're
changing channels and
you know everyone calls it the craft you
have to learn your craft
and i mean you just think like there's
disgusting yeah casting you
cast like the people that are in there i
mean it's just the terminology is all
there
it's promoting and just sort of like you
know brewing witchcraft remember when i
used to watch harry potter i had the one
you had a one year when i actually knew
some of this file
wow isn't that crazy see people always
go
um you know when they when we do a show
like this and they'll always write in
you'll see it in the comments i'm sure
you know no kids are gonna like
actually go out and do that kind of
stuff well there's a prime example right
there i haven't done the research
there's so much research even newsweek
when they cover
in the led about witchcraft on the rise
in america
newsweek covered which uh
witchcraft on the rise in america and
this is a secular
magazine and they said could it be
the you know the growing up on harry
potter or even yoga they mentioned yoga
in there and we got christians today who
don't even know about that what is it
like the
third fastest growing religion
what yoga no i'm just like yeah
yeah it's it's been growing a lot people
well kids may not
watch something and then turn around and
do it right away but when you watch
something it's within you
that's right if someone makes a
reference or a joke is cracked you're
going to relate to it and probably
laugh or if a group of kids are together
and then they start it'll
probably be harder for that kid to
abstain from that because he's watching
he's in it peer pressure exactly
so i mean once it's there it's there it
can come out at any time
and a lot of what we do is dictated by
our subconscious so these things are
going in there and then they're just
laying dormant until
the right situation happens and then
they'll come out one thing i thought was
interesting too she said they're holding
this
gigantic book with a huge pentagram on
it and she's got guys all on her and it
looks seductive
but if she had a bible oh stop shoving
your religion down my throat so
so i just had to share share with you um
you know uh
i got an email from youtube the other
day um we had a
video clip on video mission and it was a
a
girl sitting on a bed reading a bible
and they took it down
because they said that it violated the
youtube laws of
of whatever and that it was
inappropriate deemed for the age range
of whatever
and she was literally just sitting on a
bed reading a bible
like nothing seductive nothing at all
like this and i'm telling you like
this is okay like this is all over and
that's fine but reading a bible is not
like wow
here's a crazy statistic this is from
newsweek
magazine and this was published in
2018 in november okay um
1.5 million practicing our potential
practicing which is across the u.s
witchcraft has more followers than the
1.4 million mainline members of the
presbyterian church
and that's just ones who admit it yeah
there's a lot of
people who won't admit that they're a
witch so those are potential practicing
i mean they're not
saying that they're all but they're
talking about how it's dramatically
rising especially among millennials
because they're rejecting christianity
and i think they're looking for
something of of of tangible power you
know what i mean like they're they
they're they're not seeing that same
sort of thing within christianity and so
they're looking for something well how
do i
validate that there's something out
there beyond what we can see and hear
and touch and you know
and and it's like if they would actually
just build a relationship with christ
and see that he does in his way yeah
it's like when we we
when we really order our lives after
after what the bible and what jesus is
really wanting us to do then then he
shows up in our lives in a mighty way
so if he's not showing up you got to
kind of like work backwards and say
what yeah what am i not like you know my
has my relationship not
correct you said a lot of millennials
are falling into
witchcraft in those spiritual practices
because they're rejecting christianity
does that speak to the fact that there
is no middle ground
you know before god i mean whatever the
devil
what i think it speaks to is
yeah maybe that but what i really think
probably the root of it is
is they're growing up and they're seeing
a lot of
hypocrisy and they're they're also
not realizing the power of christ in
their own life
and because of that they're looking for
power somewhere else
and they're getting something tangible
in other things like wicca and so then
they're like oh wow yeah
i mean this is this is power i can feel
it yeah i can feel it something's
happening
instead of you know instead of realizing
yeah hypocrisy is there but
what how can christ change me
how can that power you know make a
difference in my life
and i don't think they're getting it
because it's not being
either taught or realized
in the churches that they're going to
and
and it's interesting though like wiccan
is more or less what
power i can like obtain as opposed to
like
god you know working his power it's
all about god versus us and i'm i'm
gonna make this happen
or you know christianity is like god's
going to make it happen
well here in uh last year it was a new a
new show on netflix
and the latino netflix
siempre bruja means uh always
uh witch you think of witchcraft you
think dark
evil lives in that when you see a word
that says that with flowers and
you know it's pretty and it's daytime
and it's like you know there's nothing
dark about that whatsoever
that's the shift that they're i mean
doing even in different cultures i mean
it's like
they're putting this thing out there
like oh look how pretty and flowering if
i had to guess i'd be like what is it
yeah beautiful summer there's not
something
you know blood dripping down and you
know pentagrams that's phase one right
that's the hook that's right
the real thing yeah yeah and yeah the
next slide uh in the beginning of the
show
uh you know the show they a long time
ago
this lady was it was a witch and
uh they found out you know back to you
know dark ages tell that
they burn you you know dead and there's
something happening about the
this show because it's comedy
and you know witchcraft and love
right and it seems like something
happened to her you know
that she come alive in today's
age oh okay so she's from like 1500
that she has to know anything about your
cell phone so like a reincarnation you
know kind of like a comedy thing like
everyone is this you know and
and she doesn't know how to control uh
her powers like wow that's magic yeah
yeah stuff like that you know she's
trying to find i mean
putting the comedy thing there like that
but at the same time you know she's like
yeah i know the hook and she's
practicing you know
magic you know you want to start and and
i mean you showed a little bit just like
the craft yeah yeah yeah
and interesting you know they had those
tattoos the stars and everything
and ouija boards yeah this is just in
your face
it's not all the stuff i'm showing you
is just what is in the show
you know she's practicing and doing and
she found another
witches and nowadays and they go to the
to the beach and doing all these
practical
you know yeah this looks all these
scenes were almost
identical with the craft the levitation
the pentagram the
ouija board and even being on the beach
with the bonfire
as they're invoking the spirits it's
literally like uh
you said this is a recent show yeah that
was that was last year
yeah so this is another way of just
rebooting the craft
yeah yeah but in a different culture you
know what i mean like it's really
interesting how
like you know the devil's working and
yeah and all these different
avenues whether it be different
demographics or different
different ages you know i mean he did it
in our day and age
now he's doing it to our kids his day
and age yeah
it's interesting but let me tell you
remember i started with the with the
craft
i believe next year or this year
halloween oh this year and halloween
just just a few more days
the craft legacy they're redoing it
again
the movie the movie yeah speaking of
craft reboot so here here again we see
the seduction the girls laying down two
of them are holding the hands
pentagram right there in your face on
the cover
it's either being seduced by women or
like you said like a beautiful picture
of flowers and things like that
remember practical magic oh yeah yeah
there's another one that kind of took
that approach you know
just too attractive women you know
they're nice
what is with that yeah why is that why
is it always led by the women i mean
that's kind of interesting right
like what's this i know which is for the
woman so what's the man
wizard warlock warlock
which is that i've seen before too
i don't know why i wonder does this mean
that there is
more women that are involved in the
wiccan religion
i mean statistically there are
can you be a male and be part of the
wiccan but i think so
women are beautiful to look at even with
other women you know girls will say oh
you're so pretty
that doesn't happen with guys right
right so i mean if you've got beautiful
women on a cover of a poster then girls
are probably gonna want to see it too
like they're drawn to it maybe not
sexually attracted but it's just
something
beautiful about it you know right right
right maybe
it's the devil trying to pinpoint
everyone's weakness
you know so when you when you think of
women you know
the attractive point is you know power
or like
yeah trying to be more than than
your physical self trying to acquire
more and for a guy well they're visual
so use seduction
but the end goal is is witchcraft very
good
if you think about society you know it's
it's largely been i guess like
male dominated you know like it's you
know in business it's said to be like
it's a man's world and these kind of
things
so for women i think there's that draw
of power and like well
i want to be able to take this into my
own hands and exactly
you know manipulate things um to my own
end
well yeah even in the movie the first
one the girl put a love spell on the
dude and he was
like falling around like a puppy and
stuff so yeah all that power
over man even yeah and so
after 25 years of the first the craft
you know now it's coming again
it's been so far yeah 25 years
and just coming for another generation
you know i mean it's kind of like okay
let's teach this new generation
you know once again you know how do you
witchcraft you know in the beginning
sadly the ones who grew up on the first
craft are parents now and they're like
oh
i want to take my dog yeah and they're
excited
i actually looked up a reaction video of
people
reacting to the new craft and every time
they're just like oh
you know they're so excited about this
religion
witchcraft is a religion and
you don't see people responding that way
when the next pure flicks movie came
you know especially not people of the
world that's weird you know
and it's just so strange to me that like
people would want to invoke spirits like
if you if you see any testimonies of
people who have invoked spirits
is it ever flowers and roses no i mean
it's like
fear and you know they like can't sleep
and they're being tortured and like
why would you want to do that i mean
that's just like
asking for trouble i think like what
kids say you know
just we are as human we just want to be
able to control
something and when we are able to do
magic we can control like anything like
an object or a person yeah we're control
freaks yep
basically yeah and we see the
pentagram uh once again the new movies
you know very interesting that they're
putting a pentagram on the forehead
you know the fact that you know
symbolically speaking
in the in the christian world you know
the frontal lobe is obviously the
the seat of your morality your
spirituality and your will so that's
like putting the seal of
satan on your forehead and saying like
to your mind
yeah that's very you know yeah
interesting
and right here is the yeah the parallels
of the first one and then and the second
one
all about showing this levitation and
stuff
i just think it's ironic that we see
stuff like this
but we when you see it in a different
light it's not looked at the same when
she's laying stiff and floating up it
looks like witchcraft or something but
we see movies where people are flying
and floating around all the time you
know
it's magic and it's just oh it's fairy
tale
the ouija board is actually been on the
rise too
look at the next slide look at this i
mean you can get ouija boards at
walmart amazon kmart click the thing
it says enter the world of mis of the
mysterious and mystifying with the ouija
board
you've been you've got questions and the
spirit world has answers
and the uncanny ouija board is your way
to get them
what do you want to know ask your
questions with a friend
using the pinnacle or the they call it a
planchette
and comes with the board but be patient
and concentrate because the spirits
can't be rushed
handle the ouija board with respect and
it won't disrespect you
ages eight and up and walmart
that's that's scary people say this is
just a popular game
it's just nonsense or whatever but they
tell you right there they're telling you
what it is ask the spirits the spirits
will tell you
and the ouija board has the the sales of
the ouija board have gone up 300
since 2014 when the movie ouija came out
that's a statistic but it doesn't affect
us it doesn't affect us
and yeah that when when someone says
that i have a feeling that they're
focusing on like
outward expression of it like their
actions but what about inwardly and you
we were talking about the frontal lobe
okay so the frontal lobe is a seat of
decision and um
and all of that so when you're in taking
everything but christ what is film
filling up that frontal lobe that's
decisions where do you draw your
decisions from by the information you
have in your mind
so yeah it can affect we should look
inwardly as well as
outwardly and the inward leads to
outward so it's going to express itself
somewhere down the road you know what's
crazy ouija board
on amazon has 1684
and they let's see 4.3 out of 5 star
ratings
4.3 out of 5. because it works that
means 1600 people
love this like reviewed it like bought
it reviewed it
and you look at the questions and the
comments and it's
pretty crazy probably sharing
experiences and everything which is just
building it up even more
you wonder if some of them are like
sarcastic a little bit like this one's
like
bought this for my daughter and she
loves it exclamation mark has used it to
summon so many demons
well worth the money i'm just like wait
a minute
surely that's not yeah the article are
real the article i read that said
in 2016 or 2014 uh the ouija board has
gone up 300
it said it became the christmases must
have
it became that was the christmases must
have list but let me tell you guys
uh you know halloween you know
in mexico translating spanish
is the day of the witches
oh so you actually celebrate halloween
well we don't celebrate like october
31st
well when i was growing up because i've
been in united states for 21 years
so when i was just growing up i mean it
was halloween it was like a party and
and stuff like that but we didn't do any
candy or anything you do that
and november 2nd is that the day of the
dead
and that is just maybe like a
promotion or like
in the clubs or something like hey is
party here come over here right but
it's not like you have to dress or
i mean it's nothing i mean you know but
it's party you know
it's partying everything but uh it's
the thing is that in mexico or in latin
america
we put that title the day of the witches
yeah we we hide our you know halloween
what does that mean you know but
they're the witch you'd probably yeah i
just know what's up like that
yeah and november 2nd is dia de los
muertos
and the thing is the in mexico is the
huge tradition that
that day i mean you honor the death
it's kind of like here in the united
states kind of like memorial day okay
i mean you don't honor the dead but kind
of like well
those people that die you know and more
focused here in the united states about
those people the veterans or you know
people in war stuff like that or you
remember your
loved ones and you go to the
grave the grave and you know cleaning
you know stuff like that but in mexico
midnight to midnight i mean like the
next day
i mean party and let me tell you this
the pictures the
i mean candles flowers uh you got the
pictures of the loved ones right there
and lots of flowers and let me tell you
food
always has to be food right in mexico i
mean the bread and everything
and i believe in and the bible says that
uh
any food it is
offered to the idols i mean it's about
nation
you know to jehovah and i don't know if
he's
right then my dad used to tell me and
say hey
we can buy them but if those ones is
already in the altar and and they if
they take it to
to give it to you don't need it whatever
only in the in the marketplace
so and then it's a huge celebration in
the streets
wow mexico city was a huge it looks like
the race's day parade man
oh yeah it's very huge and every day
this like
they celebrate the the death you know
and but this is during the day mm-hmm
yeah night time it probably goes into
the night time it's just
crazy and it gets real freaky you know
different towns whatever they do
you use uh they do you know practice mat
you know
witchcraft and voodoo and and he
practiced that yeah the day to stay home
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's the the
traditional you know you know
you grew up you know and mexico's you
know it's catholic faith
and and all the traditional stuff so
grow up as a christian it's kind of like
your friend's calling you like hey you
want to come clean out you know
no i'm not you know tomorrow you know
stuff like that
yeah i do remember having like questions
like that as a kid like you know
why why isn't it okay to go to the grave
and you know you're not you're not
praying for the dead but you can
remember have good memories about them
the family coming together and you guys
just celebrate life
yeah that's that should be all right
right yeah i think so the bible talks
about david's
tomb is with us to this day i'm sure
that people would come and look at the
tomb yeah that was david i don't know
stuff like that but let me tell you guys
i'm sure you guys know you know harry
potter
i mean big thing you know in yeah it
stopped
they keep coming out with movies don't
they oh they they have this
they had a final season there she's
written other books and that's where the
fantastic beasts thing comes in yeah
that's right
so i just wanted to share with you guys
you know a song of statistics about the
book
of harry potter 1997 to 2012
the cells there were more than 225
million copies
worldwide translating into 65
languages but that's only up to 2012.
yeah 2012. but let me tell you about the
question
is how many books of harry potter have
been sold
until 2020.
from the beginning up to 2020. how about
you guys so i would guess
so from 2012 on or from the be from 97
to 2020.
since you know since 97 to 2020 but
let me tell you 97 to 2012
he was 225 i believe yeah so i'm going
to bet that you're bringing this up so
then there's going to be a sharp
increase of sales
like a billion or something like that
yeah i don't know i would guess maybe
800 thousand 800 million
800 million let's go nine nine
well it was 500 million copies
so for eight years for only from 2012
it was 225 in 2012
those are just books they're just books
no movies no nothing you know no posters
yeah the
the movies are really a dumb down
version of the book they say the real
indoctrination comes from the books
like the real teachings in the books not
necessarily just the movies
yeah we're talking about you know those
books like that right you know you know
sometimes you you read a book and
there's a movie show up and like you
know for two hours like
oh the book was better you know i mean
the movie was just yeah i remember
parents were real excited because their
kids were
wanting to read you know that was like
one of the
things that was like oh they want to
read my kids reading what are they
reading oh witchcraft
books but they're reading right
and each one of those books if they're a
thousand pages to me that's like reading
the bible yeah you read six of those
books you read the bible six times you
know
i think i read the twilight book i think
i read all the lord of the rings books
oh twice
yeah it was like dictionary yeah twice
i don't know if they're big i just know
the movies are long the books are
thick and and another question i'm sure
you guys going to be asking but what
about the bible right
yeah i mean what what's that right
greatest selling book of all time
yeah so the 10 tops most read the
books in the world you know that's uh
the four
i believe no the third one it was uh the
harry potter but the bible is
it's 3 900 million wow
so i mean it was sold you know over the
last 50 years
that amount the top three books are like
heavy on ideology that's interesting but
after that
it's like lord of the rings yes the lord
the rinse
is it's number four on that one
yeah wow yeah
davinci codes on there twilight sagas on
there
wow so now on the in the new movies of
craft what do you see yeah i mean
looking at these images what do i see
worship what do you see these girls that
doing
dude holding hands and praying lifting
their hands up in the air
they got a book at the book and weka is
a it's a religion
yeah those are those are almost the same
elements as in the sanctuary
yeah yeah you're the table of showbread
reading
you've got the you've got the praying
for instance
you've got the sharing with your friends
that's like the witnessing aspect
of the world yeah it'd be interesting to
to take screenshots from a movie like
god that's not dead
show people praying sharing the bible
raising their hands and show these and
be like how come you like this
but you won't watch this or you're
actually attacking
the movie but this is just a show like
this is definitely religious this is not
some neutral ground like uh
entertainment or whatever
yeah but it's kind of interesting that
people accuse christians you know
movies of pushing i believe yeah but
what about these movies
yeah i mean if you just ask somebody hey
you want to watch god's not dead with me
oh you're trying to shove your religion
down my throat
i like to watch the craft oh cool yeah
yeah
so now that we looked at some of these
witchcraft movies and see that they're
not
just fantasy or some kind of neutral
ground but it really is
a religious thing it's spiritual
look at what disney's put out called
upside down magic
reena we're here welcome to sage academy
you've been accepted to the world's
greatest magic school for the world's
greatest magic
students sage has five distinct schools
fuzzies flickers flyers
fluxers and flares
i wish i just had little more control
over wacko animals i turn into
was there some llama in there it felt
like a little bit of llama
but now you're probably very clear as to
which school you are
in lori look awesome what does yours say
you
um let's see udm
welcome to the school of upside down
magic so udm means
upside down magic because you're wonky
and you're weird and your magic is
defective
but we get to do magic though right no
we do not why can't we study magic
because your magic is the perfect host
for shadow magic
and udms are its sole target
you will stay down here you will not
practice magic
and your magic will die
come on i'm gonna get there i'm gonna
prove to the entire faculty that we can
be taught
we can do things the right side up way
you can be
the shadow g is your best opportunity to
fall even further
behind we need to keep you here to
protect
humanity
so was there anything in there that
stood out to you that seemed
did it all just look okay
i mean it's interesting that it's like
upside down and it's like we're here to
protect humanity
when it's like you know these things are
actually destroying humanity
i mean it's just like opposite of what
you know is really going on
when i see that trailer i just see a
kid's version of the craft
literally all the same elements
everything that was in the movie the
craft
was in this and what is what does the
bible call witchcraft
an abomination which is
which is actually like something god
absolutely hates yeah look at this next
clip
you just think about fire and ploof
i think about a cat and i turn into a
terrifying abomination
that's why we're going to sage they're
going to teach you to be
the best abomination you can be
the best you can be the best
i mean it's it's almost like can we
sugarcoat can we
just you know dumb it down to this
kid-friendly
version and then use the terminology so
that kids think now think about
think about what's happening here a kid
is watching that
listening to that i guarantee you a kid
is not reading the portions of the bible
where we understand where this is
coming to be an abomination yeah i mean
i mean i think
you know i've read these verses to my
kids but if i actually
like went and asked them today which i
haven't read it to them in a while
and said hey what's an abomination they
might be like
i don't know but if they sit down and
they watch something like this that
programs their mind
now like an abomination oh it's
something funny or something to be
desired
well either way yeah either way the
context she's saying everything i do is
just an abomination like it's not good
well they're gonna teach you be the best
abomination wow so they're going to
teach you to be
whatever that bad thing is they're going
to teach you to be the best one wow
yeah but i'm going to show some
screenshots here
from the craft and from this show and
look how exactly similar they are we saw
the pentagram in the forehead
did you notice that just in that trailer
you could count probably 10 to 12
pentagrams in
a disney movie upside down blatant
wow right there on the i mean it's
everywhere banners
this desk the t-shirt just straight up
in your face pentagram
the levitation yeah that's what we were
talking about those girls were playing
light as a feather stiff as a board they
were levitating
and the craft when she was the camera
showed her feet
so her toes were sliding across the
floor it was like scary and creepy
but this kid floating right up hey
that's funny excited yeah
it's colorful why why is always that
like ooh
like wow you went off the ground like a
foot like you know what i mean like why
is that
so just like oh wow for people when it's
like
very often dude yeah but it's still it's
like really like
like like you ever wanted to fly yeah
sure
but i mean there you go yeah if they
could only see if the veil fell down and
you saw
two demons on either side like right
right terrified
yeah that's going to be crazy disney
loves to be like all-inclusive right so
they have princesses from like many
different cultures and ethnicities and
they've uh have different religions too
they've had hinduism
and included against spiritualism now
they have witchcraft do you think
they'll ever
touch on christianity i don't think so
right
she wears like a really nice dress all
the way up fully covered
no no no makeup or earrings
kind everyone and then in the next frame
you got
their books you know they're living by
this book like a bible
but in the movie the craft it was a book
called the craft and then this one is
called
a primer of shadow magics i want you
guys to look at that
word look at the way it's spelt and is
there anything interesting about the
spelling of this book
shadow yeah and the magics has a k why
is it spelled with a k
if you if anybody would just google that
alone you don't got to add any other
words just
google magic with a k look what shows up
so yeah
magic thalima magic is the context
magic in the context of aleister
crowley's thelima is a term used to show
and differentiate the occult from
performance magic
this is differentiating the occult from
so when they're looking at a black book
that looks scarier than the book on the
craft
literally so it's almost like magic with
a c is
the performance version of it that's the
disney version of it
magic with a k is the real life evil
evil which is now that is i think i
think it's rather scary
it's like the like sleight of hand stuff
illusion like
magic versus the dark hulk
stuff occult stuff i think that's the
distinction yeah
and this is the the show disney for kids
just to be clear is one okay and one
isn't so you can go into the practice of
illusion
and there's a line between that and
spiritualism
well i think the very basis of illusion
is based on deception
so i think on that premise alone it's
like this this this is not something
that i don't i do not see jesus up in
heaven going hey guys i got a trick for
you yeah i'm giving a deck of cards
you know what i mean no like it just
isn't going to be something that you're
going to experience in heaven i don't
think
what about scaring your kids though come
here i got to show this
oh i'm all for pranks let's do it
just to clarify my black belt lessons
they were named
after a term that meant illusion
because the way you were manipulating
the body
was designed to make
make you think you were doing one thing
but then you were doing another
so for example if i go and i hit him in
the back of the kidney
the reaction is that would puke you know
you kind of react to that it's designed
you know like nerve
reaction well then it opens up the
entire front
because that's you know protruded so
then you're doing something else
to the front so you're kind of designing
how you want them to move
so that you can create further pain but
it's
you know it's an illusion you'll block
and you go around behind and
that kind of stuff in other words not
for good
yeah but illusion so
and right here on the cover you got the
pentagram so i mean
it's all tying together we see a disney
show now
called upside down magic they have a
black book
spelt with a k which is
aleister crowley is saying this is the
occult this is straight up the occult
the pentagram which is all over the show
they're not hiding it
they're levitating they're making fire
come out of their hands
it's exactly the same stuff it's it's
less sugar on this
but we've been so desensitized over the
years to think that this is just fun
that now you can be a little more open
pentagrams and everything
i can't imagine what it's going to be
like 10 years from now you know i i
wonder why that's
that's why jesus you know made that
statement when he said you know not
everybody that says
lord lord will will be saved right and
he says you know
get away from me you workers of iniquity
you know there's going to be a lot of
people that are
quote-unquote followers of christ that
are like look
look at what we did we we cast out all
these people and demons in your name and
all this kind of stuff and he says look
i don't know you
because you guys are working with us i
think that's where the distinction
between
our christian walk and the way the world
works
it has to be a clear line it has to be a
clear distinctive
you know separation and this is just
i think inching you closer into that
mindset and it's it's playing with the
devil's fire
mikey can you help me to read acts 19
19.
yeah also many of those who had
practiced magic
brought their books together and burned
them in the sight of all
and they counted up the value of them
and it totaled 50
000 pieces of silver acts 1919
so this is not a new problem right
i mean this is a problem that i think
the devil has been working with
different cultures
throughout time and you can see the
the the trail of which witchcraft and
sorcery
since the very beginning yeah i mean
look at this this is this is this is a
prime example like
something happened in that apostolic you
know
time where people realize this is not
good let's get rid of this
let's put this away and needed to burn
them
you know what i mean like don't sell it
don't give it up yeah exactly not like
you know donate it to the local
library i mean this was like get rid of
this thing
and so you know i think we're at that
same stage now where it's like it's
becoming such a commonplace we need to
just separate ourselves from it and not
have anything to do with it
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally and let me
tell you uh
and you know right here in the bible say
when they heard the name of
god and jesus you know it's like you
need to
you know you need to burn all those
books but let me tell you 50
000 pieces of silver i mean that was
spendy i mean i don't know if you guys
know but i mean i was watching this
guy's testimony you know coming you know
worship
you know the devil for like 25 years he
was
he had like maybe like a hundred
thousand dollars
invested on stuff wow because all those
you know like they want to do all this
stuff i mean the two their
bats or something i mean it costs you
you know three hundred dollars
i mean do you want to go to the cave and
get it or you want me to just sell it to
you here
you know i'm saying all these blood
things you know what they suspend it
yeah you know books are one thing but
you know it says in exodus 22 18 you
shall not suffer a witch to live
i mean it's steep penalty and
old testament times you know it's like
nope they don't live sorry
that's that's the end of that yeah when
you come into the land the lord which
your god is giving you you shall not
learn to follow the abominations of
those nations
that shall not be found among you anyone
who makes his son or his daughter
to pass through the fire or you or one
who practices witchcraft or soothsayer
or one who interprets omens or a
sorcerer or
who conjures up spells or a medium or a
spiritist
or who calls up the dead
it was a a key point in the beginning of
that did you guys catch that
in the beginning no not even following
don't learn don't even learn don't watch
don't learn don't have it in your mind
yeah and what are you doing by watching
all these little like things you're
you're learning
about them yeah yeah the information
so i hope you guys you're watching you
know this led you you know just
you know we're trying to expose you know
we're doing these things
but learn and share with other people
you know i mean this
the truth you know what the word of god
is saying
because we need we need christ we need
more christ in our life this time of the
year is such a temptation for people to
go oh let's watch
casper or whatever it's like i don't
know why it's like it's october it's
halloween like you
you just oh we gotta watch those
horrible movies
just don't yeah and all the trailers for
all the horror films and stuff come out
well the craft is being released on
halloween why it's fitting right
so once again i mean the bible he the
lord says it's abomination to me i don't
want to you
learn it i don't want you practice
because
it's not just about you but also your
kids you're going to be bringing that to
your kids to
sacrifice your kids in the idols i mean
do you want to
bring your kids to the idols of
sacrifice and all stuff i mean we can
just
put out lots of videos i'm sure you know
out there more crazy ones they i mean
kind of what people practice you know
and we just graphing everything
um i can hear the the questions now or
the accusations like man you hypocrites
like you just said don't learn but you
guys seem to be really knowledgeable
about this stuff
it's like no well there's a difference
between learning it and being aware of
it you know we're all aware but
do any of you know how to cast a spell
like have you ever read the craft book
no like we we understand that it's wrong
we're aware of these things that are out
there that we should avoid
but we haven't sat down and watched all
the series we don't you know know how to
invoke
spirits and all these things that's what
we're saying don't learn well most
people are watching them because they
want to
they want to be entertained where we're
saying i'm going to figure out
everything that's wrong with this and
show it we're not going into it for
entertainment value
but we don't even watch them like like
literally i i want to
i want to make that clear that we're not
sitting down just like
watching these things all day long to
try to even point out what's wrong with
them i've come to the place where i
don't even
want this in my head and so it's like i
can read about it i can
you can watch a trailer you can you can
do a little bit of research on the
internet about it and within a short
amount of time you understand
what's going on and like why you should
not but i don't need to sit down and
actually
watch it to know what's wrong with it
you know just like that upside down
magic man in the trailer i mean
i mean just like three minutes yeah
pentagram pentagram yeah
yeah right revelation 18 23 the light of
a lamp shall not
shine in you anymore and the voice of
the bridegroom and bride shall not be
heard in you anymore for your merchants
were the great men of the earth
for by your sorcery all nations were
deceived
so in the book of revelation the last
book prophetic
end times all nation okay yeah end times
it says all nations is going to be
deceived
by what by food by by sorcery
so i have a question for you guys i mean
that's why sometimes we started that
seminar right like
when you're coming to work this morning
i mean do you see any sorcerers you know
right there
doing spells and chicken with no head or
something
but the bible says the old nation is
going to be deceived
so it must be a little so what is it yep
yep if we i think it's like everything
else if
we get um dumbed down with
familiarity with sorcery we're less
inclined to spot it and be
sensitive to it down the road and so
it's just like kind of conditioning us
like uh yeah you know like if we watch
violence all the time
when we see violence in the street we're
going to be less less apt to it i think
the same thing applies to sorcery
yeah yeah totally uh but before we're
going to be finished this
this episode i just want to bring you
know some promises you know we want to
hear something good you know we want to
hear
what the law has for us on promises to
help us out
to go to fight darkness and i'm sure
you know we find a lot of them but i
just have two of them but i believe
those two it's a small
but powerful that's what you know we
sometimes we kind of like you know
small powerful and acts 18 10.
acts 18 10 for i am with thee
and no man shall set on thee to hurt
thee
for for i have much people in this city
so the promise is that
god is going to be with us nobody's
going to hurt you
nobody's going to attack you that's what
he said amen
yeah don't have that mindset of elijah
you know i'm the only one
and he's like no i have like thousands
all over the world yeah
yeah yeah we're never alone and also in
proverbs 4 14
please candy help us yeah it says enter
not into the path of the wicked
and go not in the way of evil men so
don't even go
there man i mean you know sometimes we
say like okay please don't touch the
stuff you know it's you know it's just
you know younger age you know your
parents tell us that and the lord is
always telling like please don't go to
that path you know
of the wicked you know no i mean don't
go
i mean do not walk in that and walk with
the way the evil you know it's going to
be destroy your life
so i just want to you know share with
you guys you know what's going on and i
believe that
you know sharing the light of christ and
this crazy world
we cannot wait you know just to to see
to to see
our our creator so in the in the
beginning of this episode we were
talking about
upbringings and how you know we all grew
up christian
but the culture and the society around
us wasn't really
upholding our christian beliefs and we
had halloween and what was the name of
your
day of the week day of the witch right
what practical tips would you have for
parents watching or even young people
how do you stay out of the path of the
wicked
out of evil men's way how do you keep
yourself separate from society as a
christian
when it's all around you first thing you
have to do
is um not be afraid of being different
i remember when i was i got moved around
a lot of different schools
growing up there was one one school i
have some distinctive memories from
i was in fourth or fifth grade and
i was friends with this jehovah's
witness
little boy and i remember at halloween
time
um he and another girl who was a jedi as
a witness
they had to go out of the room for all
the activities that went on at school
of course school is you know all they
were doing is just you know let's have a
party and some cookies and candy and
this kind of stuff and
i don't know maybe even some of them
were dressed up but
they were not taking part in any of that
and i thought
man i feel sorry for them you know they
can't be a part of the fun
and all that but you know looking back
on it
really feel sorry for everybody else
yeah
you know because it's just inching you
that much closer to these kind of things
and so i would say don't don't be afraid
to be different daniel's friends were
not afraid to be different they
stood up when everybody was bowed down
so
you know god is with you no matter
how few in number you you think that you
are
yeah i love that answer because you know
when you're
younger you you want to fit in
everything i don't know why we have the
desire to fit in but
as older now i'm like i'm i'm
i'm proud that i'm not like all them and
it's like i don't want to be
like a sheep like everybody else i'm i
want to be different even as a teenager
i want to be different you know
and so i'm trying to teach my daughter
that now early i'm telling her like
you know when she goes to hang out with
somebody or something i say
if they want to do something that is bad
like you be the shining light you be the
salt you be the one the good influence i
want you to influence them don't be
influenced by them
i want you to be the shining light and i
just try to make that look like
that's the that's the thing that you
want to be you know i lift that up
as a good feature to be different and to
be
positive when everybody i said they're
going to try to bring you down because
they
know that it's wrong and they don't want
to go down alone they want to bring you
with them so i was like you stand for
truth
i think another thing that i try to do
at least my children as well
is try to to open dialogue with them
talk with them and then get them to be
able to help
make those decisions as well so it's
like you know i'm trying
my job as a parent is trying to teach
that child to be able to make those
decisions so that when they grow up and
they're not within my care
they've got to stand on their own two
feet and if i make all those decisions
for them all the way
even though they're going to choose
things that i don't like and i if i keep
that dialogue open and i say you know
this is what the bible says is what god
wants us to to order our lives like
and then help them make those decisions
i think that you can you can
get them strong to be able to make those
choices to be different and not feel
like
so pressured by society i think it kind
of goes back to that
like what you're saying is there's a
mental shift that needs to happen
because
we it's like we think that if we do
something different we're going to be
alone
we don't want to be alone that's what
the devil's playing on is we want to be
included because we don't want to be
alone
but the reality is you're not alone you
know but that's that's the lie that
devil is trying to tell us
each is that you're alone if you do that
you're alone you're alone you're alone
but you're not alone
good point god says i will never leave
you nor forsake you
and so that's we just have to have that
mental shift and realize we're not
alone that'll be cool for christian
parents to come together and create a
community for their children from young
make gatherings fun for the kids you
know they're seeing all the other kids
go trick-or-treating and playing and
doing those things well
make it known that within the body of
christ it is fun
it is it can be light-hearted and to to
have that for the children as well
yeah i think it you want to be honest
with your kids too like
we've raised our kids to eat a
plant-based diet so
you know i know some people have strong
feelings about that whatever
but we're always honest with our kids
you know because we my wife and i both
grew up eating meat
and i told them chicken is tasty yeah
i'll be like
totally i mean is was the burger good
you bet it was good
i liked it you know did i like the
chicken yeah i like the chicken double
chips i don't
eat i don't eat it
because of health reasons it has nothing
to do with the taste it's never had
anything to do with the taste like
does it smell good yes does it taste
good yes and so we're always honest with
him
like yeah it tastes good like all these
like really
sweet and you know decadent things
they taste good i mean we'll be honest
with you it tastes amazing
but it's not good for you and so we're
not gonna sit there and lie because i've
heard of people do that you know like oh
that
that tastes bad and then their kid tries
it and they're like
this isn't bad you know you don't want
to lie to your kids
i think that was the that was this issue
that i hear a lot with drugs
i think a lot of parents were like you
know if you try it once you're going to
get addicted and it's terrible and
you're not going to have fun and
you know your life's going to be
destroyed and then that kid tries it
once and it's like the first time their
life wasn't destroyed and they're just
like well then everything my parents
said was a lie
and then from there on out it becomes
more of a problem so yeah you got to be
honest with them and just say hey look
sin may be exciting and fun for a season
but the long-term effect of that is
going to destroy your life and
and you know that's that's that's what i
see here with this
you know what i mean yeah maybe exciting
if you watch these movies or if you you
know engage in witchcraft and
this and that i mean there may be some
elements that you're like wow this is
amazing and feels powerful
but the ultimate result is that it will
destroy your soul
yeah i always
you know my girls that you know they
were going to a christian
school and then later on it was six
years of
homeschooling then the christian school
uh for halloween
they're doing halloween they're doing
harvest something party or something
like that
it was more like a like a like a sort of
a fall fest
yeah fall festival or something but they
dress
not as a wheelchair so it's not scary
but you know like they still dress up
and they do fun things whatever and
i didn't want to i didn't like the idea
either you know this is my personal
thing i don't know
and i just want to you know it's open
yeah because it's so close you're
totally on the line
what is it you know like do i need to
stay home i mean
are you taking me and then my girl was
like you know hey
all my friends are going to be over
there having fun you know and and their
games and everything you know
yeah and there's something like and and
i know some churches they
they do that too and yeah just
they don't go anywhere but you know they
dress uh whatever so i just want to
oh what is your uh you guys
tags i seen an interesting video on
trunk or treat
and this guy it's it's where a church
parking lot
people pull up with their cars and they
open their trunks and there's candy all
in there
so it's a safe place for christians to
come and get candy and
and not be out there in the world or
whatever but uh this guy
a christian youtuber was walking up to
one of those he went to a church
on the church property and went up there
and it was like
uh you're a christian like oh yeah like
this is my church
and he's looking in the trunk and
there's skeletons and spiders
and everything hanging down he's like
what's up with all this death
and stuff they're like oh it's just you
know it's just decoration halloween or
whatever
yeah it's like he said you know this
looks no different
at all than halloween like what's the
point of even having this
it was it was pretty eye-opening to see
that even the christian
version of halloween still had death
everywhere you know the veggie version
i think you know if you're trying to
basically see how close to the line you
can get in that application
yeah you might as well do it at that
point um i i don't like that i don't i
don't really have a problem
with with dressing up so to say if you
have an alternative
and it's a different alternative um i
know my kids they
they love to like you know put on a
little outfit and like you know they
they'll
try on funny clothes or something like
this and so you know any kind of excuse
to
to have a kid be able to do that but it
can't be in the same like
exact like you know it's like almost
whitewashed version of that
activity i think it just needs to be
something totally different and i
remember the schools that i grew up
they did like a fall frolic type of a
of a thing and they had games and they
had you know people that would make
funnel cake and
food and this and that and it's like it
wasn't halloween
but it was something that like the kids
got a chance to go to and have fun and
play these games and
do something safe yeah and so they
offered something totally different but
it was like
yeah and then i think it took the kids
minds away from
what that activity was doing on that
night and it became this totally other
thing so
i think you know if if at all possible
you know
make a separation it's i think it's okay
to have an alternative in certain cases
um but just don't make an alternative in
the church parking lot with witches and
goblins
and be like okay it's safe now you know
what i mean yeah
so throw on a bonus promise third john
11. beloved
do not or maybe not promise but advice
do not imitate what is evil but what is
good
he who does good is of god but he who
does evil
has not seen god yeah and
i i can't wait to the day that we get a
chance to see god
you know i believe that day is coming
soon so we hope and pray that uh you
guys will stay
in the path of the truth and that uh you
will
let the light of christ direct your
paths and uh
we thank you guys so much for tuning in
to led live here and
and for checking us out if you're new to
this channel please
consider subscribing we've got a lot of
cool content that we
like to put out and and uh we're always
trying to take
what's going on in the world and focus
it through the lens of the bible
and also i just want to invite you guys
to like
our little studios in spanish and i know
you guys i know you guys speak english
but you never know you have a family
members
or friends and you share with us uh you
know share
the channel and little acidos thing
espanol we thank you guys so much for
watching we'll see you next friday
[Music]
you